the humanitarian crisis in Mali the
regional spillover of the conflict with
Al qaeda-linked rebels who sees the
North last year and the huge task of
Molly's political and economic
reconstruction topped the agenda for
african caribbean and pacific deputies
meeting their European counterparts this
week in Brussels yo con familia de Paz
le frontier Denali Eddie I continue
Africa say das de deporte internacional
rostro de say de souza deporte module
eight what money order or his hundreds
of millions of euros have been pledged
for reconstruction and an international
stabilization force right now though the
focus is on election scheduled for the
end of July objective the set forth the
stabilization a doper mettre la
protección efficace de population sabine
SEO to nollie media / metro organization
D'Alessio Kevon voir la esta la she
owned on Carly's team and Lopez de this
Embley brings together 78 acp deputies
and 78 m eps in a twice a year forum
this year's most pressing issues poverty
hiv/aids violence against women and
children food security and the
continuing trend in Africa for coup
d'état and conflict in hot spots niveau
de la ville de la capitale la sécurité I
gravimon manasi Laura de Xiang Jima
polity la serda tadalafil San places on
mobile is a poo ramune la Paix Paulo
disarm Emma des sa rebel para la de
mobilization running underneath it all
resentment at the exploitation of
Africa's natural resources a global
development partnership needs to address
the unsatisfactory and in some cases
tragic exploitation of the natural
resources of a CP States Africa's
blessing rich untapped natural resources
is also its curse creating resource wars
between Western countries and eastern
countries mostly China such it ever was
from colonial times to the present